getting a college education is a 20-year
investment when you're growing up poor
you're not accustomed to thinking that
far ahead instead you're thinking about
where you're going to get your next meal
and how your family's going to pay rent
that month besides my parents and my
friends as parents seem to be doing just
fine driving taxis and working as
janitors it wasn't until I was a
teenager when I realized I didn't want
to do those things by then I was 2/3 of
the way through my education and it was
almost too late to turn things around
when you grow up or you want to be rich
I was no different I'm the second oldest
of seven and was raised by a single
mother on government aid in Queens New
York
by virtue of growing up low income my
siblings and I went to some of New York
City's most struggling public schools I
had over 60 absences when I was in
seventh grade because I didn't feel like
going to class my high school had a
fifty five percent graduation rate and
even worse only 20% of the kids
graduating or college ready when I
actually did make it to college I told
my friend Brennan how our teachers would
always ask us to raise our hands if we
were going to college I was taken aback
when Brennan said Kareem I've never been
asked that question before it was always
what college are you going to just the
way that question is phrased made it
unacceptable for him not to have gone to
college nowadays I get asked a different
question how are you able to make it out
four years I said I was lucky but it's
not just luck when my older brother and
I graduated from high school at the very
same time and he later dropped out of a
two-year college I wanted to understand
why he dropped out and I kept studying
it wasn't until I got to Cornell as a
presidential research scholar that
started to learn about the very real
educational consequences of being raised
by a single mother on government aid and
attending the schools that I did that's
when my older brothers trajectory began
to make complete sense to me I also
learned that our most admirable
education reformers people like Arne
Duncan the former US Secretary of
Education are Wendy Kopp the founder of
Teach for America had never attended an
inner-city public school like I had so
much of our education reform is driven
by a sympathetic approach where people
are saying let's go and help these poor
inner-city kids are these poor black and
Latino kids instead of an empathetic
approach or someone like me who had
grown up in this environment could say I
know the adversities that you're facing
and I want to help you overcome them
today when I get questions about how I
made it out I share that one of the
biggest reasons is that it wasn't
ashamed to ask for help in a typical
middle-class or affluent household if a
kid is struggling there's a good chance
that a parent or a teacher will come to
their rescue even if they don't ask for
help however if that same kid is growing
up poor and doesn't ask for help there's
a good chance that no one will help them
there are virtually no social safety
nets available so seven years ago I
started to reform our public education
system shaped by my firsthand
perspective and I started with summer
school research tells us that two-thirds
of the achievement gap which is the
disparity in educational attainment
between rich kids and poor kids are
black kids and white kids could be
directly attributed to the summer
learning loss and low-income
neighborhoods kids forget almost three
months of what they learned during the
school year over the summer they return
to school in the fall and their teachers
spend another two months we teaching
them old material that's five months the
school year in the United States is only
ten months if kids lose five months of
learning every single year that's half
of their education half if kids were in
school over the summer then they
couldn't regress but traditional summer
school is poorly designed
for kids it feels like punishment and
for teachers it feels like babysitting
but how can we expect principals to
execute an effective summer program when
the school year ends the last week of
June and then summer school starts just
one week later there just isn't enough
time to find the right people sort out
the logistics and design and engage in
curriculum that excites kids and
teachers but what if we created a
program over the summer that empowered
teachers as teaching coaches to develop
aspiring educators what if we empowered
college educated role models as teaching
fellows to help kids realize their
college ambitions what if we empowered
high achieving kids as mentors to tutor
their younger peers and inspire them to
invest in their education what if we
empowered all kids as scholars ask them
what colleges they were going to
designed to summer school they want to
attend to completely eliminate the
summer learning loss and close two
thirds of the achievement gap by this
summer my team will have served over
4,000 low-income children trained over
300 aspiring teachers and created more
than 1,000 seasonal jobs across some of
New York City's most disadvantaged
neighborhoods
[Music]
and our kids are succeeding two years of
independent evaluation tell us that our
kids eliminate the summer learning loss
and make growth of one month in math and
two months in reading so instead of
returning to school in the fall three
months behind they now go back four
months ahead in math and five months
ahead in reading ten years ago if you'd
have told me that I'd graduate in the
top 10% of my class from an Ivy League
institution and have an opportunity to
make a dent on our public education
system just by tackling two months of
the calendar year I would have said nah
no way what's even more exciting is that
if we can prevent five months of lost
time
just by redesigning two months imagine
the possibilities that we can unlock by
tackling the rest of the calendar year
thank you
[Applause]